1日1食お金ぬ牛丼にして1週間生活し
たらタイズどうなるの
こんにちははじめさそうです
岩瀬ました a 私あてました以前動画で
紹介しました1ヶ月で9キロ痩せたんです
けどもどうやって急遽痩せたかっていうと
オートファジー生活をしてたんですよそれ
でちょっとアレンジを加えて僕の場合は
オート端生活って言ってたんですけども
簡単にいうと1日1食ただただ食べる回数
を減らせば痩せるだろうというそしてお腹
が空いてる時間16時間開けると体の老廃
物の中使って体を動かしてくれてめっちゃ
戦みたいなと実践してもう余裕のよっ
ちゃんイカで1か月で急遽痩せたことが
できてなんといまだに毎日ではないです
けど基本的には1日1食生活を続いており
ましてごらんくださいこれ痩せてから僕
体重毎日つけるようにしてるんですけども
74キロだった家はもともと74キロだっ
た夫とかもう65キロずーっとキープして
y 携帯じゃバーンレベルのは1日3食
バック v したときそれ以外全治一食で
もう毎日アイス食ってるんですよ毎日
アイス食っても一日を1色だけにしてれば
全然体重をキープできているんですけど
もう私気づいてしまいました1日1食って
どうの量までならいいんだろうもう全然
普段はハンバーガーとかねえライフとか
デザートの銃とか一色で結構色んな事本当
好きなも食べるんですよ多分それでも一日
の消費カロリーよりも摂取している
カロリーが低いからロンドンやせていく
っていう最強の状態になっているんです
けども私と思いましたその1食をキング
牛丼にしたとき人の体ってどうなるん
だろうさって10選思いましたスピアーノ
キングゲートどういうものか改めて説明し
ましょう簡単に言うとすき家の裏メニュー
なんですけども牛丼の並盛りのニックの量
約6倍
[音楽]
アホなカロリーがすごいですコロニーなと
2284キロカロリーリッジに自分なん
ですよ11分の香りぴったりなんでまずで
体重減るが増えないかもわかんないたので
ルールとしては4日1週間キング牛豚1日
1回食べますご飯はそれだけ栄養の
バランスか何かと有利そうだね1オーナー
がビタミン剤とか怒らせていただくんです
けどもとりあえず今日から1t
ショッキング中どんだけ食べます
まあ
食べきり
ます
多分これでたんじゃ変わんなかったらまず
で一緒にすごいよ何食っても太らないと
思っていただいて結構だと思いますご飯
食べる以外はなんの変哲もないいつもの
はじめしたその生活をさせていただきます
やー
飽きそうだなまずどうなるかまず読めない
ですけどもねちょっと後勢いでやってみ
ますわ
道まずは今を知ることから始めようがね
はいみなさん今の体型しっかり覚えておい
てくださいこれがキングフードを食べる前
で実際私はこんな感じでございますでは
生活内の体重を量っていきましょう
んスバル人気だどこで準備してんだよねー
6ず4.4 k ですこのガリガリな男が
今日が1週間市一色だけどのキング牛丼を
食べるとどう体重が変化するのかせっかく
痩せてるんで見てみたいと思いますでは
早速すき家に行ってきます
ん
さあ一に爪外れましたキング10度生活
まずは東京の好きやから始まりました
というわけで一日目のきんぐぎゅう動画
多分基準になるということでまぁ霊圧さ
強いの観点でこれから1週間キングヌード
ん見ていきたいとおもいますいただきます
といういうわけで始まりました1日目
とりあえず食べれるか動画ですね胃袋が
かなり小さくなってる気がするんで
そもそも食べれるかどうかというのが
かなり気になっていましたはい
今口の中に入った
文字にも起きております分待っていうのが
マジの感想
クレカ動画ですね結構暑かったね
緊急度こんなついになって感じでちょっと
走りを食べてるとけっこう時間がかかり
そうだったのでスプーンにお使いで食べ
させていただきました
勢いで食べないと胃袋がどんどん南下
苦しくなっていく気がしてスプーンで
駆け込むように食べさせていただきました
うんベースはねもう見ててわかるんです
けど一回も止まらずにガンガンいってい
ます
が苦しかったリス2に
sony ちなんで仕方ない苦しいのは
そんな気がしておりますけど一応で手は
止まらず音がんが食うことができました
はいスイッチ完食でございますよく食べ
ましたしっかりと音が見つけないでご
ちそうさまでした2人前に食べたんです
けどやばいずにあれマジで
2200kcal ですがただ北今市全治
1食にすべてかけている否定かつ2カ月
続いてるんで正直まだ余裕ありますどうぞ
キングいうドンヴィッツもより空と生きる
様たらなんか一色あれでは追われても
ちょっと本さあ魅せですけどもこういう
企画なのでこれはあと6日間続けたいと
思いますじゃあまたなぁ30th 掴み
やってまいりましたこれは浜松 no
付き合かな静岡県の浜名つの
すき家で食べさせ量をびっくりしたし両
os ながらめちゃくちゃ暑い強い
なんかコツ黒子みたいな
普通に夕食ですぎでびっくり so-net
もしっかりとたくさんいただきます
いただきます
まぁちょっと僕猫舌なんで結構暑いの苦手
なんですけどもそれでもしっかりと笑っ
ちゃうぐらいルートですね本当に
あとこれ実はのイベントのサイズに食べて
ますはい時間との勝負でもありました
おっと他の女がしっかりと火見開いて
バグっていきます
ただ全然クリエイティブで問題ないと思っ
たらまたバグってしまいました眼球開いて
ますね
あついあすいとか本当に温度が苦しかった
ですねしっかり食べてきます
終わるわけにいきませんからね
なんでその目を見開いたんだろうね
いれば選択してもらう
yardbirds ちょっと写真
あの
ファンの方に行って買ってきましたね
のタイムロスがどう耳鼻科もほんど
どーーーんとぷでされたゆえの気持ちなん
ですけどしっかりと柄も食べることができ
ましたありがとうございます大2日目
食べることができましたお店によってその
x ドンの温度が違うんですけどもを見
たらめっちゃ暑かったねこれ普段からする
と大ブロックですなってくる敵にはホン
ジニョンとれたしていただきましたえっ
味に飽きてきてるけどまだ全然最後用意し
てですって
麻生頑張りますはい3日目でございます何
かやや疲れてねって感じが表情に出てるん
ですけども普通に流す事が忙しかったりし
て疲れています3日目の金牛丼こんな感じ
です意外と業は少なめだったんですけども
アーサー汁の量もいい感じで結構食べ
やすい部類かなと思いましたさあ今
ゆっくりといただきますありました3日め
ちいきましょう
をずっ
んですね久々に乱獲も立ち寄りましたうん
キングダークっていうのも見られてまず話
だったらうーん
[音楽]
はいしっかり完食しましたこれぐらいの
ルートプリキュアというわけで3日目
終わりました気づいたんですけどスーツ二
食にしてから食べ物には気なくなったん
ですよ1色がすごい楽しみだからね前まで
キングビュー度食べたら最後の方なんか
あついあきてて苦しかったんだけど3日目
にして気づいたら何が違うかっていうとね
あずに開けなくなってます美味しい最後
まであと4日間が悪いハイ2で4日目で
ございます4日目の緊急どうも果たして
どういう顔なるかなぁまぁ全体的には普通
だますねちょっと勢が少なめでご飯が
白かったです
ただこれねーよね歯医者行った後ます売っ
た後ですごい赤味噌でまぁしっかりと
すっごいとした空想天尊下がりながらも
救っておられました
[音楽]
ブーバこんなにキングドンが多いのか毛量
が
ぬーんぬー
[音楽]
っていきますエイ
ございません
気持ちをしっかり込めていきましたん
うん
これ
米も多かったんですね絶対に
ただもう空しかないと思うんですけど
ムーディブリッジ
[音楽]
bouvet に行かないんでなんとか
気合いで完食することができました ap
メーカーディっ
日記グー
ドゥました
まぁ今回も割とオーソドックスなんじゃ
じゃーん金融どうでしたねはい多くもなく
少なくも
部作3に曲げて後輩たちもたくさん一緒に
食べてくれました一人です
食べ始めます6日目で装置そっと苦しかっ
たん
阿佐谷北そうですよあきてはいるんです
けども全然お腹すいてるから食べてるよ
ちょっとためについているぐらい若干
苦しくなってきたなってきました
しっかり食べました家族です6日目が
終わりました味にちょっと飽きてきたが
って感じですけども全然はで美味しいです
この感じだと多分最後まで美味しいん
でしょうね
ハンバーガーが食いたいですさあ最終日7
日目です良いよ最後となりました1週間も
-10どけばほぼ身体の中ちゃうできぬ
けど
なんか全然結構遠出しててですね静岡ざる
ところで最終秒ございました
もうなんか移動おい時間のだよ中で俺は
難治食べと一樹つかさ4ホッ7
のか彼を食べ
狂ってやがるついていながらも実際10時
移植これだけでマジでカロリー的にどう
至ってるのかわかんなかった本当にトップ
林てくるのが気になってますなぁいい感じ
のキングいうカッターいい数のキング牛豚
にしたガスとも
いただきます
感謝しっかりと食べさせていただきます
もうなんか慣れてきました件牛丼
おや様子がおかしい
結構熱らが最終目が本当にねぇ結構言う
[音楽]
ん
てなんだか
[音楽]
映って高校は何とかやりきるしかないと
思ってそのうちになっている
5分ほどピンコロと
ひらめく8連覇
運営を会計6番国製もセラミック入れたら
ちょっと高かったスポット動きが止まった
大丈夫か
[音楽]
思ってない
すごいのここまで飛ばなかったんですよ
最終日だけちょっと手が止まっちゃったん
ですけどもいよいよ残りわずかこれが
食べれば俺の一週間が終わりです今口に
運んだ
分かった
ここで完食ですん
[音楽]
はいというわけで1週間はありました
とりあえず牛丼以外のものが食べたいし
野菜はこの1週間1回は食べてないから
サラダが食べたい欲がすごいですけど
よろしく野菜を図って終わりたいと思い
ます
味がトースターやオーブン
よっ
とりあえず皆さんチャッこいつた
google 皆様お待たせいたしました
1週間
1日1食 king 牛丼のみで生活させ
ていただきました
彼に使わせて痩せてくださいもうホントに
マジで1日1食 king 牛とだけを
食べましたそもそもこの企画やる前から
ずっと基本的に1日1食で生活してたのに
胃袋が小さくなってちょっと思ってたん
ですけど全然金牛の食べれて何だの言って
もの食事よりあんぱく室は絶対多いから
ちょっと筋肉ついたかなっていう気がし
ました賛成が目指せトイズに米が多くに頭
摂り過ぎでお腹肌がくすむらしくてなんか
ちょっと肌が黄色くなった気もしました
そんぐらいでもなんで本当に毎日
柔道をに1200キロカロリーぐらい食っ
たっていう
2時に7日間の金融の模様でばらつきが
あったんで一概にこのかなりですとも言え
なかったです5日目とかやけに多かったも
というわけでみなさんが気になっていると
言うの結果発表行かせていただきます数字
が6 the 4.4キロから一首頁移植
緊急のだけ食べた男は何虚になっているの
でしょうかちなみにこの1週間の生活の話
すると割といそうだし買ったです商品
カロリーを結構多かった気がするし1回
あの超運動したりした日も1日だったんで
運動は比較的している方の一般男性として
提案させて頂けると助かりますじゃあ体積
を持ってきます
えっっ
んんん
いっ
では端から整備いただきます本当に合わせ
ない感じが俺が気になってる曲だからまず
ねそのつまんないかもしれないですよ
ダンダラ布団ってちょっとだけ素に戻り
たいけどやりますいけない
ん
うん
ですねっ
すごいすごいすごいすごいすごいすごい
まあまあノーカットでここに来の形でかっ
[音楽]
voodoo
すごいすごいよう皆さん今ので証明され
ました1日1すぐ何グってお太りませんあ
そうとも限らないかわかんない甘いもの
食べてないのも大きかった気がするんです
よ俺だから1週間緊急度しか食べてない
からアイスとかお菓子とか一回も食べて
ないんですよこの1週間決してそんな
なんかから他にヘルシーな食べ物ではない
と思ってるんですけど
[音楽]
変化なかったしや俺が退社いいのがあると
思いますさあなとか言ったし運動もしたし
ただ普通キング牛丼食ったら太るけどな
っていう固定概念があったからビックリし
ました本当に体重の変動はなかった抹茶
食わず対戦ってことあるでも混ぜからね
うわすごいというわけで
みなさんこれでまたひとつを明らかになり
ましたねキング牛丼食って太らなかったと
いうことはよっぽどのことがない限り太ら
ないと思いますみなさん
何日1食
何食っても布団ないと言っても過言では
ないと今回の軽傷で明らかになります俺は
頑張った甲斐あったがザップっウルッとき
てロレ辛かったんすよ1週間金牛とだけで
大石普通に他のも食べたいしなんか怖い
野菜ぼくいたらたし行ってよかった
me
なんか全霊の歴史を変えた気がしました僕
ぐらいのも30近くになった家は1センチ
色でいいと思います何しても痩せる打て
まして
いいキャットねー
柔道は4年ぐらいかんとこ